mais d'abord Lucas la mobilisation des
agriculteurs se poursuivait aujourd'hui
excédé par la réglementation européenne
qu'il juge trop contraignante pour leur
permettre de rester compétitif en Union
Européenne mais aussi une rémunération
trop faible les agriculteurs ont mené
des actions dans toute la France et
notamment à tour aujourd'hui des
tracteurs étaient notamment stationnés
devant la gare tourangel très tôt plus
tard ils se sont déportés jusqu'à la
préfecture Faustine lunau et Clémence
dos que les ont
suivi ils étaient mobilisé dès 7h30 ce
matin une dizaine de tracteurs ont
investi le parvis de la gare de tour
amené par une vingtaine d'éleveurs et
sérialiers ils ont distribué des tractes
au passants une action organisée par la
Coordination Rurale d'indréloire pour
dénoncer la réglementation européenne en
matière d'agriculture et leur trop
faible rémunération en France un poulet
sur deux qui est consommé est un poulet
qui vient de l'étranger donc qui ne
respecte aucune enfin aucune qui n'a pas
du tout les même règle ni la même
qualité mais du coup il est plus
compétitif en prix donc c'est c'est
c'est surtout ça qu'on dénonce on
dénonce
aussi l'effet néfaste des primes pack
néfaste dans le sens où on nous promet
des choses et quand la fin de l'année
arrive et que les versements sont faits
et ben il y a toujours un pourcentage
qui manque le groupe d'agriculteur a
ensuite été reçu à 16h par la directrice
de cabinet du préfet pour exposer le
doléance un entretien juste après que de
remorques de fumier ai été
symboliquement déversé devant les
grilles de la préfecture c'est peut-être
un petit peu dommage de salir mais il y
a comme ça qu'on peut se faire entendre
alors satisfait on a donné nos
revendications on était à l'écoute des
notes ont été pris tout toutes les notes
vont remonter
au au ministère sur toutes les doléances
qu'on leur a donné on é très bien écouté
le dialogue a été intéressant d'autres
actions coup de point notamment au
niveau des péages de et de sign devrait
être réalisé demain journée durant
laquelle le gouvernement a déjà prévenu
qu'il fera des
annonces